[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres türkisches
rezept um zwar machen wer merzig kräfte
also hat dolmetscher das heißt dieser
frikadelle leser frikadelle
ich bin doch ich sagen das muss nicht
unbedingt typisch seien die typen mir
und sagen ist für den jahren aber werden
sagt er und die anderen sagen das ist
für uns das heißt es gibt es überall
oder ja ich mache halt die version die
ich von meiner mama kennen die kommen
aus der türkei und das wege unsere
türkisch sli linse frikadellen oder ist
alles andere als deutsch und es ist
alles andere als fleisch halt ich denn
dieses rezept ist sogar veganen da ist
kein tierisches produkt mit dabei es ist
eine richtig tolle vorspeise ich es aber
auch ganz gerne mal zur hauptspeise also
muss ich halt ein paar mehr belchen und
die kann man entweder länglich formen
oder auch zur runden kugeln formen und
ich finde es sehr schön vor allem für
die ramadan zeit kann man das auch ganz
toll servieren
für die wm ist genial weil und
fingerfood kann man einfach aus der hand
essen und die zubereitung geht so
schnell und so einfach ein bisschen
erinnert an die kräfte
wobei hier die zubereitung viel viel
einfacher ist also man muss nicht ewig
kneten und ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
zutaten die ich war dafür verwende dafür
verwende ich eine kartoffel 450 gramm
rote linsen 600 milliliter wasser
ich habe hier feine bulgur 180 gramm
drei zwiebeln 50 mm sonnenblumenöl oder
olivenöl jeweils einen essen paprika
mark und tomatenmark den saft einer
zitrone einen bund frühlingszwiebeln und
einen halben bund petersilie hier
nämlich immer gern die glatte und dann
noch die gewürze salz pfeffer und chili
die linsen habe ich jetzt unter
fließendem wasser abgewaschen
die kommen jetzt in einen topf da sind
noch ein paar echte gebe auch mit rein
und die müssen jetzt erst mal weich
gekocht werden daher kommt jetzt hier
das wasser noch mit dazu
damit der deckel drauf und einmal
aufkochen lassen und in der zeit kann
ich die kartoffeln schon mal schnee
gestellt habe ich sie schon
ich kann sie noch schnell fein würfeln
und die kommt hier auch mit rein
[Musik]
und die kartoffel schneide ich im
prinzip nur so klein
damit ist einfach schneller gar ist und
es dauerte etwa 20 bis 25 minuten so
lange muss das hier jetzt köcheln also
erst einmal bei höchster stufe aufkochen
stellt dann die hitze herunter und dann
dank mitteln und in der zeit kann ich
jetzt auch schon mal die zwiebeln klein
hacken
jetzt kann ich das öl in einem separaten
topf geben und kurz erhitzen und darin
werden dann die zwiebelwürfel angebraten
und dann so etwa fünf minuten
[Musik]
ich habe meinen linsen noch ein bisschen
wasser zugefügt ihr müsst einfach mal
probieren ob sie wirklich schön weich
sind die dürfen nicht bis fest bleiben
sondern das ganze muss sowieso eine
matsche pampe geben also ich habe zehn
mal 400 milliliter zugefügt und jetzt
ist alles richtig schön verkocht und man
kann sie auch wirklich dem kochlöffel
dann einfach ganz gut zu drücken
den topf oder den herd mache ich jetzt
aus da kommen jetzt noch die gewürze
dazu salz pfeffer und chili
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch der feine bulgur
dazu der muss ja nur noch ziehen also
der muss jetzt nicht aufgekocht werden
das heißt ich kann das hier kurz
einrühren und den deckel noch mal drauf
geben
[Musik]
und hier drüben bei den zwiebeln wir
sind jetzt auch schon gar
da kommen jetzt aus tomatenmark und
paprika markt dazu und dann kann ich
alles ganz kurz abkühlen lassen
ihr wisst ja mein manager bisher
unromantisch und ich kriege ja keine
blumen vornehmen wobei ich auch keine
will weil ich kann nichts damit anfangen
also bringen wir meine kamera jung immer
ein blumenstrauß mit morgens divisional
was nicht glücklich macht und bund
petersilie zwiebeln kann ich jetzt schön
fein hacken und dann alles vermischen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich alle zutaten
verbinden also die kräuter und die
zwiebel sinn fein gehackt da kommt jetzt
die linsen masse rein
das reicht dann von der türkische
großfamilie dann die zwiebel mit dem
tomate und paprika mark dazu und dann
noch der zitronensaft das auch unbedingt
notwendig da braucht man wirklich
einfach so ein bisschen säure und ihr
müsst dann einfach nur mal abschmecken
mit salz und pfeffer und auch
zitronensaft und alles schön verkneten
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr die masse formen
ganz traditionell könnt ihr das so
machen einfach eine portion in die hand
und dann so zwischen den fingern drücken
dann habt ihr so eine längliche form
also wird es meist angeboten
ich will jetzt nicht so machen denn es
erinnert mich zu sehr an kräfte und
jetzt möchte ich kleine bändchen lieber
kommen und dann kann man so wirklich so
mit einem haps auch in den mund stecken
und die werden jetzt geformt und später
dann mit salat angerichtet
[Musik]
hier richtig gerade den salat aber ich
habe jetzt hier kopfsalat verwendet und
am besten im team hat die inneren teile
diesen ein bisschen knackiger und die
äußerung könnt euer zu einem salat
verarbeiten und die habe ich jetzt
gewaschen und dann trocken geschleudert
das ist auch ganz wichtig das einfach
nicht so tropfnass sind dann hier schön
anrichten und das macht dann auch echt
was her und da könnt ihr jetzt die magic
kräfte darauf anrichten
und dann ist man sie auch wirklich mit
dem salatblatt dann werden die finger
auch nicht schmutzig und noch ein
bisschen granat adressierung und chili
zum beispiel drüber
[Musik]
jetzt sind sie fertig und so auf einer
platte gefallen sie noch richtig gut
dazu auf jeden fall etwas granatapfel zu
observieren ja wo es ums ganze
bedenken muss dass krieg gleich überall
granata funktionär
man muss nur darauf achten ich finde der
beste granatapfel serbisch wert der zu
100 prozent aus granatapfelsaft bestehen
ohne zusätzlichen zucker bis in chili
noch drauf und dann darf probiert wird
und das essen ist auch nicht ganz
einfach
ich geb dir mal das mittlere einkommen
mehr salat der kleine elfe und salat rät
wickeln und dann bis ° zu essen man darf
das was sein muss muss gehört richtig
lecker und vor allem ist es auch mehrere
tage im kühlschrank haltbar
falls ihr das rezept nach machen möchte
dann schaut auf meinem blog sallys -
blog.de vorbei ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen uns
das nächste mal kommt r wir probieren
allen drei tagen sowie behalten
ja aber ich will wie solaris sowie immer
gesagt meine eltern machen aber es aber
so lange halten die ja gar nicht mehr
gleich gegessen
ich finde du bist ein bisschen fett kann
ist ein ziemlich fade to fail
die russen ja nochmal rein kommt rein
das hat mir öfter machen und gar nicht
so ungesund gerne linsen dran hat doch
wieder gesund
nein ehrlich gesagt aber wenn es gesund
ist kann es nicht schmecken aus spaß
hatten die jungs wie die raucher als als
deutsch türken
das kann auch nach machen
also räume auf und dann geht es weiter
nächstes prozent
[Musik]